بعد اسابيع من توتر العلاقات بين بولندا
واوكرانيا كادت خلالها ان تتحول وارسو من
حليف حميم الى خصم صامت لكيف تتوصل
الجارتان رفقه ليتوانيا الى حل لازمه مرور
الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر الاراضي البولنديه
الاتفاق الذي حمل اسم الممر الاخضر يقضي
بنقل شحنات الحبوب الاوكرانيه المتكدسه
حاليا على الحدود مع بولندا الى ميناء
كلايبيدا غربي لتواني
المطل على بحر البلطيق ومن هناك الى
المستوردين الرئيسيين في افريقيا والشرق
الاوسط قاطعه بذلك طرقا بريه يقدر طولها
بنحو 99900 م وسيتم ذلك دون خضوع شحنات
الحبوب لعمليات فحص الجوده عند الحدود
البولنديه ما سيسرع نقلها باتجاه الميناء
الليتواني الازمه بين البلدين الحليفين
كانت قد تصاعدت مع قرار روسيا الانسحاب من
مبادره تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
وقصفها عددا من موانئ اوكرانيا البحريه
والنهريه الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي كان قد
الغى الرسوم الجمركيه على الحبوب
الاوكرانيه تحرك لتفعيل خطه عمل كانت قد
اطلقتها المفوضيه الاوروبيه لانشاء طرق
بديله لصادرات كيف تمر عبر بلغاريا والمجر
وبولندا ورومانيا وسلوفاكيا لكن هذه الطرق
واجهت تعقيدات مارسها مزارعو تلك الدول
الذين تخوفوا من تح الم الاكرانيه الى
اسواقهم المحليه فتصبح بضائع منافسه ما
دفع الاتحاد الاوروبي الى السماح لهذه
الدول بحظر بيع المحاصيل الاوكرانيه فيها
لكن مع السماح للمخصص منها للاسواق
العالميه بالمرور فقط عبر اراضيها لكن
حكومه بولندا التي تواجه استحقاقا
انتخابيا مهما منتصف الشهر الجاري ولا
تريد اغضاب مزارعيها وبالتالي خساره كتله
انتخابيه مهمه س الى تمديد الحظر على
واردات الحبوب الاوكرانيه بشكل احادي ما
اشعل سجالا حادا بين وارسو وكييف وصل حد
تهديد اوكرانيا بنقل القضيه الى منظمه
التجاره
العالميه